jeder asylant ist ein beitrag zum müll
dieser gesellschaft abschieben notfalls
erschießen
ich habe mittlerweile die nase voll von
all den flüchtlingen ihr gottverdammten
schmarotzer euch sollte man alle
ausnahmslos bei lebendigem leib
verbrennen hass kommentare bei facebook
so genannte hate speech beim thema
flüchtlinge scheinen viele deutsche
facebook user keine grenzen zu kennen
beleidigungen beschimpfungen hätte
tausende neue hass kommentare werden
täglich auf facebook verbreitet
hate speech ist daher auch bei mark
zuckerbergs besuch in berlin ein thema
für hass kommentare gibt es keinen platz
in unserer gemeinschaft
bis vor kurzem haben wir uns in
deutschland nicht genug engagiert wir
müssen das künftig besser machen
der facebook-chef auf werbetour in
berlin
facebooks image in deutschland zurzeit
schlecht seit monaten wird das
unternehmen kritisiert denn der umgang
mit hass kommentaren ist bisher sehr
unkritisch netzwerk aktivist markus
beckedahl sieht facebook sogar als eine
art hass verstärker
neues hat dieses phänomen deshalb über
soziale plattformen wie facebook auf
einmal menschen voraus vom bodensee mit
menschen an der ostsee sich gegenseitig
in die kitas hineinsteigern und sehr
schnell gerüchte oder meinungen
transportieren und sich gegenseitig
anfordern
zwar können user bei facebook
beleidigende inhalte melden
doch viele der kommentare bleiben
bislang stehen der grund
meinungsfreiheit ist in den usa wo
facebook sitzt breit definiert
dort sind zum beispiel hitlergruß und
hakenkreuz nicht verboten
in deutschland dagegen ist der aufruf zu
gewalt gegen bevölkerungsgruppen
strafbar
die sogenannte volksverhetzung ist
hierzulande illegal
auch im netz für medienrechtsanwalt
ansgar koring ist facebooks
zurückhaltung beim löschen von hate
speech und verständlich für einen
mitarbeiter von facebook wird es
vielleicht nicht immer ganz einfach sein
zu erkennen wann volksverhetzung
vorliegt oder nicht allerdings muss man
natürlich sagen dass facebook ja auch
nicht unbedingt an das gebunden ist an
die stelle dieses deutsche rechts
sondern facebook könnte ja auch schon
viel früher ansetzen und auch in
zweifelsfällen die vielleicht nicht
eindeutig volksverhetzend sind die man
aber vielleicht trotzdem nicht haben
möchte einschreiten und die löschen
selbst die deutsche bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel spricht mark zuckerberg
auf das problem an der druck auf
facebook wächst der konzern reagiert
gemeinsam mit bundesjustizminister heiko
maas gründet facebook die initiative für
zivilcourage immer dort wo die grenzen
der meinungsfreiheit überschritten sind
dort muss um strafbare äußerungen geht
volksverhetzung öffentliche aufforderung
zu straftaten wo menschen bedroht werden
sollen solche inhalte vom netz
verschwinden
facebook will nun in deutschland
verstärkt gegen hass kommentare vorgehen
dafür würden hunderte mitarbeiter
engagiert diese sollen inhalte prüfen
und löschen
das problem ist nicht dadurch gelöst
dass facebook einfach kommentare löscht
sondern wir brauchen
rechtsstaatliche verfahren um gegen
menschen die volksverhetzende meinung im
internet verbreiten auch vorgehen zu
können die müssen vor gericht gestellt
werden und die müssen dafür auch
verantwortlich gemacht werden weil sonst
lassen wir es zu dass facebook
eigentlich als polizei und als richter
eine privatisierte rechtsdurchsetzung
schafft und das können wir als
demokratie nicht wollen